so i have a friend he's a really good
friend of mine and i've known him since
i was in college and he's a tough guy i
mean he grew up in a uh
under rather poverty stricken
circumstances in northern alberta really
on a frontier piece of land like it had
only been
broken 50 years before by his father who
was a longshoreman and the next military
guy good guy his father but this guy
grew up and he is tough he worked in
lead smelters and he wandered around
western canada he was my roommate when i
went to college and is still a good
friend of mine and he ended up working
with like delinquents he went into
social work oddly enough and
and he ended up working with some of the
worst delinquents in in canada and he's
a really good guy and he likes to help
people
get better
but he isn't naive at all and then part
of the reason that he was good at
working with delinquents was because
there were no tricks they could get up
to that he couldn't see right through
and that was partly because he had a
real integrated shadow i mean i'll give
you an example of him
so one day
i was living in this town called grand
prairie and it was at the height of the
oil boom and so it was a rough town and
there were lots of rough bars and lots
of young men in there with plenty of
money and plenty they come in for you
know three days after being out minus 40
weather working on the oil rigs and they
were ready to party man we had a party
one night in this kind of frat house
that i went to college in and about oh
way too many people showed up and some
of them were real trouble makers and one
we had a table that was pretty full of
beer bottles and vodka bottles and so
forth and one guy just went over like
tore the leg off and knocked the table
over and then a bunch of us got together
and chased them all out and
this friend of mine he said oh they'll
be back and so he went upstairs and he
put on some steel-toed cowboy boots it
was just like a bloody west and he came
marching down the stairs and just as he
entered the living room there was a big
knock on the front door it was these
hooligans coming back to cause grief and
he he just didn't break stride he opened
the door he pulled open the door and
there was a guy standing there ready to
fight and he kicked them underneath the
chin with a steel tool cowboy boot
knocked him right over the
the front porch and uh you know and the
battle was on but that was exactly what
he was like you know
and he had his shadow was integrated you
could he's a great roommate he
he reciprocated everything i always knew
if i bought groceries one week he'd buy
it the next like he was a straight
shooter you could trust him but he was
not naive man and that made him able to
deal with delinquents and to help them
so that's part of that integration of
that shadow
yeah um i i go very deeply into the
shadow in in a chapter in my last book
the laws of human nature
and i try and talk about how one
integrates the shadow because it's not
it's not an easy answer for that you
know people are kind of perplexed well i
have this dark side and i explain a lot
of where it comes from and how a lot of
your aggressive impulses like the room
of two-year-olds that you were talking
about
you have that as well i'm talking to the
people that have
my readers you have that aggressiveness
when you were young and it got
socialized out of you and then it got
kind of got repressed and it's like a
lost self that lives inside of you and
is screaming to come out how do you
integrate it and so the main thing is
you have to be aware that you have this
shadow side you have you can't run away
from it you have to acknowledge that it
exists you almost have to embrace it a
good parent too does everything he or
she can not to repress that like what
you want to do with children is you want
to
like you want them to be forceful you
want them to have some power
you want them to integrate that that
capacity for aggression into
let's say lucid conversation you want
them to be able to stand up for
themselves in family discussions if you
just punish them for being
aggressive let's say for talking back or
something like that you don't guide that
into more sophisticated development you
see this in schools too now you know
when my kids went to school this was so
dumb i we had a rule in our house which
was
you don't have to follow stupid rules
that's a good rule but if you get caught
you have to put up with consequences but
right so one rule was
the school had
not only could you not throw snowballs
you couldn't make them
and so they were trying to yeah exactly
you should shake your head that's for
sure it's like because their answer and
this was all politically correct
nonsense you know non-competitive games
we're only going to play non-competitive
games it's like first of all you know i
studied piaget
yeah a hockey game is not competitive
exactly because in a hockey game well
everybody no one brings a basketball
everybody plays hockey so that's
cooperation and then on the team you
have to cooperate and like if you're the
star but you never pass you're just a
dumb son of a [ __ ] you're not the star
and so there's tremendous amount of
cooperation in all those competitive
games they're integrated and this idea
that you know make children better by
not allowing them to be competitive it's
so
it's disgusting it is it's that well
that's the freudian devouring mother
right that's oh well everyone's safe and
no one's gonna ever hurt anyone and
that's kind of where a lot of young
people are you know they enter the world
where they've been called where they
think that there are no winners that
everyone is you know it's just win-win
situations and that's where they get
really shocked by the realities of the
world so all this coddling and this idea
that
there doesn't have to be a winner we
don't have to get prizes for first place
everybody should get a prize you know
all you're doing is setting your
children up for for massive uh
you know
shocks when they enter the world and
they see that it's not like that yeah
and then they get disillusioned and
depressed you know or traumatized but i
mean when my my son's hockey team
in his school they won the the city
championship which was a big deal you
know and the school was pretty happy
about that to to his credit so was the
coach but the principal who was this
authoritarian empath she was an awful
person i thought authoritarian
empathy yeah well yeah she used more
virtue as a club when it was yeah well
there's plenty of those people around
yeah she said well really today we're
all winners
and the coach had the yeah exactly no it
is sickening because it and you know my
son was just a paul bite but the coach
had enough guts he said no no
the hockey team won and it's not like
the kids in the school were jealous some
of them were obviously but most of them
were really happy like you are when your
sports team wins that yeah you know and
most people are generous enough so that
they're able to celebrate someone else's
victory without and that's the same i
saw this with birthday parties i just
bloody well hated this it's like well
every child gets a gift bag it's like no
you know they have their damn birthday
every child doesn't need a damn gift bag
and it's this is this same the same
naive trickly
and it's authoritarian too because it
imposes this kind of view of the world
it's like no it's this kid's data be
special that's why we're celebrating
this kid
the rest of them if they can't take that
it's like
there's something wrong with the way
that they've been
treated and it tends to
well a lot of my books i've tried to
remove the kind of taboo or the negative
associations we have with the word like
power or with the word ambition you know
i try and say ambition is a good thing
it means that you have you believed in
yourself you you have some self love and
you believe you're worth something and
you want to go out and achieve and and
it creates something worthwhile for
other people so ambition is a positive
thing but so many people are just kind
of embarrassed about being a human being
embarrassed about our primate nature
embarrassed about our own aggressive
impulses this is partly why boys are
failing in our schools now at a
disproportionate rate you know the the
and i see this there's an assault of the
sort that you're describing on the
better part of striving masculinity and
you know i had a friend who killed
himself because he identified his
ambition with
you know the the patriarchal force
that's devouring the environment let's
say and that's a con that's you know the
cause of of historical horror and you
might say well no one takes that on to
themselves to that degree and that's
well you can say that but that you just
don't know what the hell you're talking
about people take that on to themselves
all the time and then they they start to
identify the best part of them that
strives forward with the destructive
impulses of humanity and they're so
ashamed because they can't do anything
good then but in principle yeah you know
he tried to be as inoffensive and
harmless in every possible way as he
possibly could and it just sucked all
the life out of it you end up turning
that aggressive energy on yourself is
what ends up happening and that's maybe
leads to suicide the ultimate kind of
self-aggression
i know that i personally have as i said
i definitely have a shadow side i'm very
aggressive and extremely competitive and
i have a lot of anger
so a lot of that those experiences in my
youth made me very angry
but the way i kind of integrated my show
i'm not saying this is a model but the
way i integrated it was through my books
yeah so i kind of that anger kind of
seeps through the material that i write
and i find i can only write when i have
that kind of anger but i don't rant i
don't yell and kind of put people down i
kind of channel it into something
productive and something creative and so
i definitely do that when i'm lecturing
you know and people have commented you
know some of the people who've
criticized me that i'm an angry person
and which isn't true
but it's definitely that anger that
capacity for anger definitely is
something that gives you force and it
can push and anger definitely so
psychophysiologically so imagine that
this is obviously a thought experiment
imagine you're chasing a cat with a
broom
well the cat's gonna run from the broom
but if you corner the cat with the broom
it will attack you even though it's just
a cat well the reason for that is that
fear will facilitate either freezing or
escape right but sometimes fear isn't
the right response and anger will
suppress fear and so one of the tools
that we have at our disposal
psychologically is
anger as an
antidote to the terror that would
otherwise freeze you